Jason M cook says this hey dr. Tyson
have you ever worked with or been to the
Hadron Collider I have never been to you
got to watch how you pronounce that
because let's say horror goes in the
wrong place
I'd say hard-on Collider so I'm saying
just harder than lighter place there
yeah okay I I deeply regret that I've
yet to visit the the European Center for
Nuclear Research which is acronym doubt
it CERN and their biggest accelerator
there is the Large Hadron Collider and
hadrons or particles made of quarks and
the general description of particles
made of quarks and so and basically they
can slant protons together make very
high energy environments and they're
looking for dark matter and it's
basically the largest machine ever built
okay
it's a largest machine ever built period
ever Wow next is like the International
Space Station Wow you can say that's
built like in space International Space
Station is the size of a football arena
right let the Large Hadron Collider is
like miles in circumference look at that
go there just stand there look at photos
of people standing in the cross-section
of the collider you see the wires and
the metal and it's superconducting and
it's got its physics and so you say whoa
we can do this we can probe the Big Bang
itself giving us a little taste of the
origin of the universe in our backyard
laughs but other physicists hey did you
like that cool video huh well how about
a bunch of cool videos all commercial
free plus exclusive original content
that you can't find anyplace else all on
Startalk all-access calm